The office is so nice,
why
do you have to be that it says
xstrata tight
and
oh
if you study
I hope that now from this
love is
not safe
coast
sure
oh
what it is
I already have
and
harm evil
here
to a glory
later
[Music]
am
tell me
nothing
we can't touch today in gasteiz
been
the people
m
and
[ __ ]
what is the coffee
but the self-satisfactory factor
price
ah
from skype r
yes no
from javi martínez they are dureta
live
to the mix
look
and here they are
jazz
for you
the pac
asad
property
is easy plan email
that is
i face
buckner
[Applause]
[Music]
the experts
in general
hello
blake
martial
pac
once
and
yes
for you love me franch
hello
everyone why
not
here
[Applause]
what
do I know because it is me  killing
the altars
time
yes pickets
good morning
and
I had no cold choice
[Music]
place that when you woke up
saint nazaire
here
the ones that gave birth to you
avenue
tell
me again I'm
mainz
good to
arrive
in this
with  air
estrada speech
each young
fawcett
[ __ ]
wave mails
work
e
elements
cat
but at home
farc
always give credibility
oh
I am
never
now
to the doctor
interpretation
here back
yes
the web
monument
cat
to fill kenya
and won
and that's
it
[Music]
employment what is
no  it's true
i
the rise of cluster
after
na wai
to want
for now
here
jazz
if he gains space
well
shawn michaels
peter cloud maps
tracks opened
that is to mark
ah
sky
I am expected
to bleed
if they are good
buckner
which has
in them
[ __ ]
ward
a  sometimes
there is a little
house
the grass
waheed care and watch for lester
raúl bertrand kirchner
[Music]
there is the state siat
[Applause]
oh
here
the pac
with capital jazz
geren hawn
perhaps